hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slo-mo guys when I was a young boy sort
of hanging out with Joe glackin and all
that stuff he'd always have karang on
all that MTV and I remember being
fascinated by the music video to Freak
on a Leash by corn yeah just a bullet
just going through a bunch of stuff a
little bit of slow-mo balloons and all
that stuff and I thought why don't we
see how many panes of glass a bullet can
go through this is untempered glass and
the sound it makes when it smashes just
reminds me of kicking a ball over my
neighbor's fence into their greenhouse
and being like Oh wide quick it's
definitely the sound that precedes a
bunch of kids scrambling in different
directions
split up so we're going to be using a
nine millimeter round how many glass
panes do you think it'll go through well
I've seen things about how windshields
of cars can potentially deflect nine mil
but that's because it's on an angle it's
tempered and it's probably thicker than
this this is like eighth of an inch
thick
so we've got a potential up to 20 slots
here for glass but I reckon it will
probably get through
six six six okay all right well we'll
start with three and then more densely
populate this little block yeah if it
gets through three if it gets through
three if not um yeah let's go home this
is the Phantom TMX 7510 and I have a 85
mil lens on the front which allows me to
be plenty of distance from the danger
zone
made ready
wow
look at that some of the glass stayed
completely intact that's unbelievable
this went straight through oh God I
guess if that was tempered glass that
would have all been gone like how
definitely that behaves to the tempered
glass that's wild oh it's worth getting
a close-up of that a nice round 100 000
frames a second undo Keys oh it makes
sense of the shockwave through the glass
and powders anything in front of it some
of the glass overtakes the bullet oh
it's I guess the bullet slowed down from
the glass it's still spinning it's still
in like a normal frying pan
oh just breezing through look I like how
when it first goes through it's like a
thin dust pattern and then it gets
thicker after about half a foot about
six inches later it's really thick did
some I think some glass smashed on the
other glass before the third paint broke
from the glass from the second one yeah
I tell you what I think that's going to
go through way more than three I
underestimated how powerful a nine mil
round is I think
coming off like blown so I think in
order to make the bullet bigger in the
frame I'll zoom in just on this area
Okay so maybe from the first paint to
the second paint and then we can fill in
every slot in between okay so a nice
like close together tent yeah a nice
tightly packed tent perfect I wonder how
thick it's going to be before I can't
see through the glass because I'm aiming
at a point through I can see through the
glass at the moment I think it'll be so
uh dark exactly like it will just be
darker and darker and darker and darker
ready when you are loaded
made ready
straight through straight through all of
them straight through safe
that's a lot of glass to get through
it is quite thin Glass isn't it
I just saved an hour of footage wow from
something that happened
less than a second
okay here we go clean back
wow look you can see it slowing down you
can see it oh you can as well
it's probably going less than half of it
it's still going through the glass
though and the glass is still going
through the glass we're underestimating
how fast it's still going look it's
peaked like how wide it's gone in the
middle there and it's definitely slowed
down so much I tell you what we've made
like a bullet parachute out of glass
I tell you what that won't make it
through 20. imagine if it gets stopped
at the 20th
that is amazing is that the bullet there
yeah it's oh it is a piece of the bullet
is broken yeah it's coming to shards you
see that this bullet's like what do you
want from me
you're asking a lot now from here
yeah wow yeah that that's not going to
go through 20. I really don't think it
will it was by the 10th pane I feel like
between the ninth and the tenth pain it
lost a lot of speed it it slowed down it
was like you could I wonder if it slowed
down by the same percentage every time
after putting the speed of the bullet up
on screen you can now see that there are
several panes of glass the bullet
doesn't actually touch it seems as
though after a big impact from the
bullet it transfers a lot of this energy
into the glass and then the glass takes
care of the neck pain causing the bullet
to go through without losing much if any
speed until the bullet then catches up
again should we just do 20 straight to
20 just straight to 20. yeah so I'm
risking a GoPro here it's been a while
since we've knackered one I was I the
last person to do it as well I shot one
with a cannon I think if you'd have just
put the Phantom here
I think I reckon
in my expert opinion it'll get through
oh
oh 20 and then it will just dink off of
the the Phantom's lens to be honest that
would be the coolest in the world yeah
you have to focus pull as well
well because I'd be safe too wouldn't I
yeah yeah exactly
oh
it's annoying
oh no why is
what's going on there ah basically
because I had to turn the plank around
because I only had so much room and the
saw is a miter saw so it's on a hinge
like this yeah I had to I used it and I
was just cutting like this so the saw
only comes down about this angle but to
get about this deep in the wood yeah it
doesn't come directly down and I had to
flip the wood so I've got a bunch of
glass at the end that's slanted this way
and all these ones are going to be
slanted this way
laughs
uh I am not a professional
well I like you be oh thanks so this
whole table is about six feet well yeah
this this plank is exactly six feet six
foot fence post and going six feet wide
on the Phantom I think is just slightly
too far away like it makes the bullet
minuscule so I'm gonna miss the first
three or so okay but all the action that
we want to see is going to be around
here I think
that's freak isn't it
okay
ready made ready
oh
wow
goodness me where did it end there's
nine panes left so we got through 11.
yeah I'm glad I didn't Focus only on the
last 10 because that would have hardly
been anything but wow
look at that is there a bullet somewhere
there must be well here's the best thing
about our job
we don't even have to guess I forgot we
just go and find out yeah I bet we'll
find the bullet after watching the
footage so it was only one more paint
well that's what I'm saying I no I think
that makes sense because it was really
really your speed between 9th and 10th
I guess each maybe a different shot
would get through slightly more
you know
that's so interesting
oh let's just have a look yes let me
watch it so you missed out the first
what three missed out the first five
first five yeah but you know most of the
[ __ ] oh you're getting some of the uh
like warping of the glass yeah I mean
it's still moving it's not inaccurate
it's [ __ ] like it's on a line to go
through all of the fitter pains so it
must just have been stopped guys slowed
down so much compared to the previous
shot
goodness it's basically just stopped
Where is the you can't even see the
bullet is it just in pieces now
where is it is it even there I think the
bullet has been vaporized by the glass
look at it did it just stop it there
dead I think there's just pieces of it
it's like flowing through the air I
think it's just I think it just broke
apart
wow yeah look at these shards coming up
up here so it's not necessarily the lack
of power of the bullet it's it's
construction yeah because it's not the
speed or the power it's the construction
of the bullet isn't hard enough to allow
it to go through if it was like an armor
piercing Builder or something like
depleted uranium or tungsten carbide it
would probably just go straight through
look at the way it interacts with this
first one here
oh wow the like Matrix style liquid
glass I'll go tight around 10 then all
right this is an illustration of Entry
wounds versus Exit Wounds and it gets
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger until it's dissipated all of
its energy into its Target
and that is the glass and then until
it's just lost everything and now when
you get to this last piece of glass
foreign
Rock through it yeah so like that's
where it started and that's where it
finished isn't that crazy and that's
basically just shards of other glass
that did that shards were the glass
bitters I'm surprised it's not even a
piece that we can find
I'm gonna keep this for a minute
okay is this it
yep
that's it you found it this would be the
outer part of the bullet then there's a
Lead Core so FMJ is Full Metal Jacket
which is
this is the jacket now the lead is
obviously
somewhere else I guess that's cool look
at it you can see the the sort of
rifling on the on the just flattened by
glass yeah
very cool
what's this where
and
another oh this is it that's it that's
the lead that's the lead that's right
next to each other yeah that's it
I guess I thought it would have come
apart in more pieces maybe it just lost
all of its energy just bounced off one
two three four five six seven eight nine
so I'm missing the first four okay
much tighter though just make sure the
bullet does exactly what it did last
time yeah yeah sure yeah I'll make it
sure it does yeah loaded
made ready
safe
I think it did exactly the same thing
oh it did exactly the same thing and
it's so how immensely consistent is this
that's unbelievable is the bullet over
here as well like
what oh it's here oh
there look it just went just dropped
down look yeah look at it we might be
able to see that
wow
unbelievable look at the way it's just
compressed
that didn't separate no this might be
the shot I've wanted to film
for so long is a is a bullet bouncing
off a piece of glass I don't know if
we've got it
[Music]
oh there we go we're already booking it
boom boom
straight through the center again
it's getting slower
getting still enough
where's the bullet can you see it
doing the initial break I think and the
bullet just it's like lost all of its
energy at the ninth one
does it hit like does it make an impact
on the glass well it rippled the glass
look it broke the glass oh yeah oh
that's the sorry I didn't even
oh it's just completely stopped dead now
oh there it is
look at that point
wow
that's a bullet bouncy off just a thin
sheet of glass just a regular old eighth
of an inch thick glass that is really
cool that is amazing I'm so glad we've
got that that's special like
oh yeah it's so consistent between
totally consistent you were like you
joked to me like oh just do the same
thing the exact same thing again it's
like oh yeah sure exactly the same this
this pain has been hit by two bullets
and it's it's got It's got a scratch on
it
it's got a little ding uh yeah it's got
look there's a couple of dings on it
okay based on what we've learned we've
now placed 11 panes of glass and a
mirror so effectively our camera is now
right at the final pane of glass and the
mirror will stop us from actually having
to put the camera there and you're going
to use a ladder this time yes ready yeah
ready
[Music]
oh
got through it all gone through it all
but kept the mirror oh wow is it pretty
much bang on do you think I don't know I
mean it looks really in line with it
amazing the bullet bounced off that last
paint it wasn't the bullet that broke it
so we actually do have footage of the
bullet just bouncing off the last paint
and then the glass overtakes it wow
that's amazing I don't think I've ever
seen
anything like that from the angle like
look at when the bullet changes it's
it's angles like
I think
so we do have footage from the
perspective of the sort of behind the
glass yeah of a bullet being stopped by
the glass and then it broke later
but by a fraction of a second all this
stuff coming in from the side isn't
actually coming in from the side it's
the uh the mirror the angle so all the
glasses just hit the mirror wow
what
what the hell
well I think you can hear that it was a
good video by what it sounds like when
we
slightly adjust oh that's a lot of
greenhouses
that's a lot of glass yeah lost its life
today yeah but immense footage I can't
believe we watched a bullet
slow down to the point where it could
just dink off some glass and stop the
same exact piece of glass twice I've
said it before but still unbelievable we
and we actually got a solid answer to
the title of this video eleven yeah
eleven but it's also we knew the exact
thickness of the glass as well yeah 11
if you're using this thickness of glass
and this specific gun and this specific
bullet so not really very informative
new but to be fair when have we ever
been that useful it's true hopefully you
enjoyed that video too make sure you
subscribe if you liked slow-mo and uh
we'll see you next time we'll probably
be in the Quarry again yeah it's good
it's fun and it's fun